[Music]
welcome to auction school what five
thousand what five out of almond five to
have been told by our number one do Dave
here we go rack Andrew the Missouri
auction school was founded in 1905 it's
the oldest and largest auction school in
the world
the trains auctioneers in every aspect
of the auction confession and is known
as the Harvard of auctioneering
introduce the item ask for ten drop to
five I'll give you the five and then go
to six so we start every morning at
auction school with group drills daddy
bothered by the motor bidder
just like an athlete would warm up we
need to warm up very good okay give
yourself a hand job at auction school
the most important aspect is that
auction chant now free now for you would
throw a bid not 25 25 its soul the very
foundation of the auction profession I'm
a $20 billion now thirty nine thirty
will you give me thirty I'm a Tony
daughter bid
okay let's try that the auction chant is
two numbers the money that you have bid
and the money that you're asking for I
have one dollar bid now - now - will you
give me - to another bid now three now
three would you give me three I'm going
to don't you give me Tony will you give
me twenty feel that said that said good
job and as they sell more and more those
filler words will slur so it'll move a
little bit faster send me a little bit
or not one time on opening night two
things everything we give is anything no
Dominic things everything's anything we
give is it being 42 I'm 41 here we given
fortitude 142 thanks there on up over
hundred eight Poehler 100 Autoport sold
375 and that's what creates that nice
smooth rhythm chant
rubber baby buggy bumper basic rhythm
okay learning the auction chant in a
classroom setting is important but
you're not really an auctioneer until
you get to go to a real auction and sell
real items to real people respond to the
six hours of the TV
so by hours your way so if the student
auction you never know what's gonna come
up for sale and so you got to be ready
for anything first time in slot 75 you
got a stack of three turtles got an old
tablecloth jumper cables very useful
another stack of turtles number six six
three is a meat cleaver so one of the
most fascinating aspects of the process
is the transformation that the students
make throughout the program so often
when they first come to the school
they're hesitant they aren't sure what
they're doing a lot of them are
frightened even once they get up and
they sell and they realize yes I can do
this I can really do this you could hear
it in their voice I'm Anna
Winnie endoscopic Unicode oh my oh here
at the school it's in a mini
[Music]
chocos School in Tokyo Japan teaches
people how to be mascots because the
business of being a mascot is big really
big mascots in Japan aren't just for
sports they're for police departments
towns malls Airlines even prisons
they're a staple of Japanese culture in
Osaka alone at one time there was one
mascot per six thousand residents Kakuta
me Mom
even now I got to kill anything like me
for me the manga Medina no no that boom
cannon not that don't wanna see them so
she teaches them to wave to dance to
pose and her class is diverse he's a
former chef she's a housewife this guy
he is a professional mascot their
ultimate goal it's to perform but of
course there are rules
number one no talking in the character
don't knock on a high pedestal no koi no
yoga chitta don't you Miata Christian
mom koi wa that's a night no comment
number two don't show any skin he gave
us a look at akaroa miss a night so they
were not Connie still hyped ignited
their nominee me cetera so that we shown
it not disavow they miss a night
number three don't be rude these rules
are here for one reason a mascot is more
than just a costume
[Laughter]
tada whoa
Kira Mina yo doc a ded yo doc a de a
hurry the Tadano character today's
konnikova boy de trabajo en su cara ah
so we do particular una being a mascot
is about becoming something greater than
yourself you can escape into the
character in fact that's what you're
supposed to do you go to Mira
Papageno say Kaku kaiyani it's kataoka
Torito most of it though quite a coup
d'etat songs I this chocos been doing
this for over thirty years and her
students well they seem like they're on
the right track
keep on practicing guys
a professional Butler is somebody who is
loyal flexible discreet hardworking
honest but most important it is a person
who has the ability to put somebody
else's wishes before your own that is
what makes this profession so very very
difficult
[Music]
at the age of 21 I became a buffer
nowadays I am chairman of the
International buffer Academy the
international buffer Academy is located
in the beautiful village of simple veldt
in the Netherlands we have about a
hundred and thirty five groups 80,000
square feet completely dedicated to the
training of buffers our students lives
here in our building they come literally
from every country in the world age from
18 to 68 students learn about
housekeeping house management estate
management regular things like even
suitcase packing silver shining shining
shoes the list is enormous there is an
incredible amount of training to be done
in ten weeks
discipline here at the International
Golf Academy is very very important in
order to get a job done you need
discipline I think in order to be
successful you need discipline and
discipline your school is something we
embrace and not something that we are
afraid of here is cool we always joke
about what employers want they need a
clean toilet they want a warm bed and I
want a hot meal and those three things
are most important for everyone
my wife and I we have our own buffer and
very fortunate I've had a private
button-up in the past 17 years and this
person is very very important to me
being a doctor can certainly be a
wonderful career simply because if you
are responsible for the well-being of
the family for their happiness that is
obviously very very very important
[Music]
who to Aniak no Garmin that was in
micarta Porter Ahmedabad in ma the
austere Sameera Varma pop until until
Magento mera naam the Giovanni class -
Mia Mia 69
[Music]
you're gonna be snoot Lanka that's what
in Atlanta that what is it you don't
[Music]
wanna be saying when you go summer
Ziggler is Anna thank you
your mother and father moment Abba see
an America sorrow sorrow vitamin E
sorrow La Moneda neora must be glad to
go a dispute in butter sorrow sorrow 11
- Malloy a bank with a mammal secured
sheeter football he can never named Adam
enforcer malleable can happen Iman put
her in a killer insulator must know as
malice on turkey burger
dream of America the interlocked to
Colorado vegan dumber than
Gamakatsu Porsha Nene relax romantic and
in the townsmen anybody partner with you
and hey we were formal a gray ivory
singapura marilah kita bersama is full
graceful logic Vienna annapoorni Manuka
Raghavan motor Jenna Tata Guerra my
tickity Malaysian IRA numeral a tiny
survey Dominici Chappell na roti Jehan
ecology mr. Oberstar mogari porno for
tourism anomaly sahaja yoga you noble
Veronica lady 7 Emily Rasta interest are
several tiny fellow Bulgakov neva Bala
political Sevilla many admirable quality
who for new furniture and food Orange
Avenue family Mackie is a noble animal
aluminum for eco
[Music]
Americans we love ice cream
each person eats about twenty four
quarts of it per year and that's for one
big reason it tastes amazing but someone
had to teach Ben and Jerry's how to do
it turns out that guy he works at Penn
State this is dr. Bob Robert hold on
okay this is dr. Bob Roberts
he teaches ice cream courses at Penn
State I do I have two courses ice cream
short course and ice cream 101 side note
these are the type of books
ice cream professors read
okay back to the story part of the
reason that ice cream is so good in the
u.s. is that we've been teaching ice
cream for 125 years and Bob he's been
teaching at Penn State for 25 of those
and he's had some pretty famous students
companies like Unilever nestle Breyers
Ben and Jerry's you name the company
they've sent people that's because the
Penn State Creamery is on the forefront
of ice cream technology ice cream is a
formulated food there is no naturally
occurring ice cream you have to put the
ingredients together and process it to
make ice cream Bob in his department
they spend their time figuring out how
to make ice cream even better when we
look at studying ice cream we study ice
cream from cow to the cone so we look at
what happens on the farm what happens
with the milk
wait there's a farm we have herd of
about 250 or so milking Holsteins and
yes they are on campus so yeah he knows
ice cream but he says that he's not an
ice cream purist I'm not sure what an
ice cream purist is but I wouldn't eat
frozen yogurt if I had the opportunity
to ice cream yeah well that does make
sense considering he is the authority on
ice cream bob what's your favorite
flavor mmm Doce de leche yeah
[Music]